this is the sound of worker's off the
coast of Vancouver
they make these fantastic sounds not
just to communicate but also sometimes
to echolocate to find their way around
and to find food but that can be tricky
sometimes because well here's the sound
of a ship passing by recorded underwater
[Music]
you know when we think about marine
pollution I think we usually think about
plastics maybe toxic chemicals or even
ocean acidification from climate change
as a science journalist who often writes
about environmental issues those are the
things that have passed my desk over the
past 10 years or so but as I recently
realized when I was writing a feature
for the science journal Nature noise is
another important kind of pollution one
that often gets ignored you know maybe
you've heard of the dark skies movement
which aimed to raise awareness of the
issue of light pollution and create
pockets of unenumerated night so that
people and animals could enjoy more
natural cycles of light and dark night
and day well in much the same way there
are people now raising awareness of the
issue of noise pollution and trying to
create pockets of quiet in the ocean so
that marine life can enjoy a more
natural soundscape this is important
noise isn't just an irritation it can
cause chronic stress or even physical
injury it can affect marine life's
ability to find food and mates and to
listen out for predators and more think
of all the sounds we inject into the
ocean perhaps one of the most dramatic
is the seismic surveys used to look for
oil and gas airguns produce loud blasts
sometimes every 10 to 15 seconds for
months on end and they use the
reflections of these sounds to map
the ground beneath it can sound like
this
then there's the sound of the actual
drilling for oil and gas the
construction of things like offshore
windfarms sonar and of course the nearly
constant drone from more than 50,000
ships in the global merchant fleet now
the natural ocean itself isn't exactly
quiet if you put your head under the
water you can hear cracking ice wind
rain singing whales grunting fish even
snapping shrimp all together that can
create a soundscape of maybe fifty to a
hundred decibels depending on where and
when you are but mankind's addition to
that has been dramatic it's estimated
that shipping has added three decibels
of noise to the ocean every 10 years in
recent decades and that might not sound
like a lot but decibels are on a
logarithmic scale like the Richter scale
for earthquakes so a small number can
actually represent a large change three
decibels means a doubling of noise
intensity in the ocean a doubling I'm
not solving an estimate because no one's
actually keeping track of how noisy the
ocean is all around the world there is a
body called the International quiet
ocean experiment and one of their
missions is to try and plug the hole in
that data so for example last year they
managed to convince the global ocean
observation system to start including
noise as one of their essential
variables for monitoring alongside
things like temperature and salinity we
do know some things we know that sonar
can be as loud as or nearly as loud as
an underwater volcano a supertanker can
be as loud as the call of a blue whale
the noises we add to the ocean come in
all different frequencies and can travel
great distances seismic surveys off the
east coast of the United States can be
heard in the middle of the Atlantic in
the 1960s they did an experiment where
they set off a loud noise off the coast
of Perth Australia and they detected it
as far away as Bermuda 20,000 kilometers
away so what does all this sound like to
marine life what do they hear it's kind
of difficult to describe sound travels
further faster and
water than it does in air and it also
packs a different punch so sound of the
same pressure will have a different
intensity whether you measure it in the
air or underwater then there's the fact
that whales don't have ears exactly like
human ears creatures like zooplankton
don't even have what you would consider
to be ears so what does this mean what
is the impact on all this marine life
perhaps the easiest thing for scientists
to assess is the effect of acute noise
really loud sudden blasts that might
cause physical injury or hearing loss
beaked whales for example can go into
panicked dives when exposed to loud
noises which may even give them a
condition similar to the bends in the
1960s after the introduction of more
powerful sonar technologies the number
of incidents of mass whale strandings of
beaked whales went up dramatically and
it's not just marine mammals fish if
they stray too close to the source of a
loud sound their fish bladders may
actually explode the air gun blasts from
seismic surveys can mow down a swath of
zooplankton the tiny creatures near the
base of the food chain or candy form
scallop larvae while they're developing
well what about chronic noise the more
pervasive issue of raising background
noise from things like shipping that can
mask or drown out the natural soundscape
some whales have responded to this by
literally changing their tune a little
bit like people shouting to be heard in
a noisy nightclub and some fish will
spend more time patrolling their borders
and less time caring for their young as
if they're on high alert
chronic noise can affect people too of
course studies have shown that people
living near busy airports or really busy
highways may have elevated levels of
cardiovascular disease and students
living under busy flight paths may do
worse on some educational tests and even
while I was researching this subject
they were actually blasting out about
three meters of solid granite from the
lot across from my home office to make
room for a new house and the constant
juddering of the rock hammer
was driving me completely insane and
whenever the workers stopped for a
moment I could feel my shoulders relaxed
this effect has been seen in Wales too
after the terrorist attacks of 9/11
international shipping largely ground to
a halt for a little while in the waters
off the east coast of the United States
and in that low researchers noticed that
endangered right whales in that region
had fewer chemical markers of stress in
their feces samples as one researcher I
spoke to likes to say we were stressed
but the whales weren't now you have to
remember we have evolved to be a visual
species we really rely on our eyes but
marine life relies on sounds the way
that we rely on sight for them a noisy
ocean maybe as befuddling and even
dangerous as a dense fog is for us and
maybe sometimes that just means being a
little more stressed maybe sometimes it
means spending a little less time with
the kids maybe some species can adapt
but some researchers worry that for
endangered species already on the brink
noise may be enough to push them over
the edge so take for example the
southern resident killer whales that
live in the waters off my hometown of
Vancouver there are only 75 maybe 76
animals left in this population and
they're facing a lot of challenges there
are chemical pollutants in these waters
and they are running low on the salmon
that they really rely on for food and
then there's noise when researchers
studied these and similar killer whales
they found that they spend between 18
and 25 percent less time feeding in the
presence of loud boat noise and that's a
lot for a species that's already
struggling to find enough food to thrive
the good news as I heard from all the
researchers I spoke to is that you can
do something relatively easily about
ocean noise unlike the wicked problems
of climate change in ocean acidification
you can just dial down the knob on ocean
noise and see almost immediate impacts
so for example in 2017 the
Angora Fraser Port Authority started
asking ships to simply slow down when
going through the Harrow Strait where
the southern resident killer whales are
feeding in late summer slower ships are
quieter ships and because it's Canada
you can just ask it can be voluntary in
that 2017 trial most of the ships
complied adding about half an hour to
their travel time and reducing noise by
about 1.2 decibels or 24% of noise
intensity this year they decided to
extend the length of time and the area
over which they're asking ships to slow
down so hopefully that has a positive
impact for these whales in 2017 the
Vancouver Fraser Port Authority also
introduced discounts and docking fees
for ships that are physically designed
to be quieter
you know weirdly a lot of the noise from
a ship like this comes from the popping
of tiny bubbles off the back of its
propeller and you can simply design a
ship to do less of that and to be
quieter the International Maritime
Organization has published a huge list
of ways that boats can be made quieter
and they also have a target of reducing
carbon dioxide emissions from global
shipping by 50% by 2050 and the great
news is that these two things go hand in
hand on the whole a more efficient ship
is a quieter ship people have also
invented quieter ways of hammering in
the giant posts needed for giant wind
turbines like this one and gentler ways
of doing seismic surveys and there are
some incentives for using quieter
technologies the European Union for
example has a healthy marine system
directive for 2020 and one of the ways
that they define a healthy marine system
is by how much noise is going in those
waters but on the whole most waters
remain completely unregulated when it
comes to ocean noise but again most of
the scientists I spoke to said that
there's real momentum right now in
policy circles to pay attention to this
issue and maybe do something about this
issue we already know enough to say that
quieter seas are healthier seas but now
scientists are really scrambling to
come up with the details just how quiet
do we need to be and where are the best
places to make quiet or preserve quiet
and how best can we hush our noise and
you know I'm not trying to tell you that
noise is the biggest environmental
problem on the planet or even in the
ocean but the point is is that humankind
has a lot of impacts on our
environmental system and these impacts
don't act in isolation they act together
and they multiply so even for the ones
that are not so obvious we really need
to pay attention to them I'll tell you
about one last experiment just because
it's so beautiful so Rob Williams one of
the researchers who works on southern
resident killer whales also does some
work in Bali and there they celebrate a
Hindu tradition called me Eppie or a day
of silence and this day apparently is
very strictly observed no planes take
off from the airport no boats go out
fishing the tourists are gently led off
the beach back into their hotel rooms
and Rob Williams put some hydrophones in
the water there to see what the impact
was and it was dramatic sound levels
drop by 6 to 9 decibels about the same
as in the waters after 9/11 for an
acoustic prospector like Williams which
is what he calls himself this silence is
golden now he and other researchers can
go back to this place and see what the
fish choose to do with all this
additional acoustic real estate
I like to think of them having their own
holiday feasting and finding mates
celebrating their own spot of calm in an
otherwise noisy world thank you
[Applause]
[Music]